hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to emily is away now
we're starting chapter three in the
winter of 2007 I may be flirting with
both Emily and Evelyn but I did get
confirmation that this emily is
completely different from the original
emily from the other game i don't know
what it is about girls named emily but
i'm gonna maintain my delightful oh
Justin Timberlake ooh
I'll go rise against hey I'll be right
with me Oh Morgan
hey hold on there I'm gonna work on this
stuff uh let's see you know ah
life's too short to wait and see
designer in my own content light too
short to wait all right what do you got
for me hey greetings you alright what's
up eagle - hey yo Dawg what's up blind
your dog oh yeah we be let's see how are
you oh pretty good you see what are you
up to oh you know homework trying to
learn I'm grand
hey you should listen to some music with
me are you you drunk let's see of course
of couse let's see uh-oh
I want to lose things I want to be cool
like you
oh ass why's it got a cynic oh god I'm
getting OH
Manchester Orchestra oh I wish I could
have done that this warning is pretty
email hang on let me get to both of
these yeah
wait rude that's nice okay thank you
thank you for that that was real good
that was really good let's see oh this
is this is this is really good and what
about this one let's see here
Oh game emo indeed but you know I like
it it's cool all right what do we got
here whoa it's snowing outside do you
like snow yeah actually I frickin love
snow where is the past except for fall
you know I like fall let's see but it's
still good why are you listening to do
it
ha it's six run men jumping between it's
gonna be hard ha it sticks around my bad
I hope it's stuck around let's see ah I
still understand you I'm a smarty I'm
just feeling really down Oh is
everything okay is everything like okay
everything's whatever today just really
sucked you're the first person I'm
talking to all day let's see were you
not talking to other people by choice
see good I'm sorry for all my spelling
mistakes let's see uh you drunk
hey no offense pretty drunk just askin
you're serious is he
ha oh no is it that obvious I'm a little
let's see huh nice I thought you said
you didn't drink okay yeah I was hoping
to get better but I can tell I'm not fun
to talk to right now see ah I don't care
about that oh I don't care about is that
I don't care about that as like I don't
care if you're not fun to talk to you oh
come on I don't care about that yeah
that's that's what I meant
that's what I meant but I do and right
now I'm just like stupidly emotional
let's see I mean I'm here for you if you
need me if you need me I'm here
oh hi things change I guess thanks mark
I'm just feeling so sad and worthless
let's see you're not worthless don't say
that let's see because I'm drinking
tonight okay all right donut
you'll be fine go crazy have you been
drunk before see thanks I'm just so
ready for Trey to end and see uh-oh
Wow start fresh you have to start fresh
tomorrow maybe I have no idea if that
was the right answer
I wonder if I'll get a hangover Oh a few
times but never this drunk buffer I
wonder if I'll get a hangover tomorrow
let's see aspirin save your aspirin
before you go to bed I know all the
secrets oh boy my brain just won't stop
I'd really appreciate it if he would
[ __ ] off let's see make some tea you
make some tea
who's a bad suggestion but it's all I
got yeah that could help at least talk
to you is making me feel better
huh keep talking is something going on
thanks for the tea op let's see what's
the okay celebrating something I guess
oh and you did did it buy me no brain
yeah still a mess in my head oh boy uh
just how [ __ ] everything is Lowell let's
see em what do you mean I might just
need to vent about it
let's see I'm here for you you want to
talk always you actually want to talk
about it see I'm always here what are
you bothering you oh boy are you sure
you won it's just all a bunch of [ __ ]
look see tell me about it
I'm ready I'm ready and open for two
conversations at once I'm feeling a
little stuck okay how do you mean cool
boy it's just been a [ __ ] day I'm all
alone oh I'm here hey I'm here for you
that's me just nothing like I do matters
you know oh I know that feeling
oh boy here we go thanks you good one
I'm sorry I'm such a mess see oh come on
you're not a mess oh boy I just don't
know how to fix what to do to fix it
let's see change things up it's
embarrassing I don't want to be like
this like [ __ ] now I'm starting to cry
like an idiot let's see what's going on
talk to me know me details sit really
frustrating oh is it is it is it Jeff
I don't know I thought this [ __ ] was
over uh is this a like is this about
Steve [ __ ] yeah I think he's like the
root of it let's see how so oh boy oh
boy of course you could tell yeah it is
okay oh he's still back on the weekend
oh boy I wanted to change it you don't
know what to do let's see talk to him
you could talk to him yeah he does I see
him around all the time let's see uh
there's a guitar he likes whoa boy
I'm trying to change this name don't
love it something happen hold on see I
don't I don't know I don't care a little
company Hammond okay see I mean nothing
in particular felt this way for a while
let's see oh that's real consideration
Paul I'm very much over him is he good
for you deserve way better Oh bring up
last night with the bag regardless oh
boy let's see oh I think it more of an
[ __ ] now oh oh let's see oh my god oh
man oh [ __ ]
I got it wrong yeah I [ __ ] up huh I I
misspoke oh yeah I misspoke I'm in like
he was home oh [ __ ] thanks he vivo [ __ ]
I [ __ ] that one up Davis ah let's see
ah he's changed in college the [ __ ] oh
I've really [ __ ] that up my hands my
hands I guess so [ __ ] him
Oh has he changed his going to college I
guess so [ __ ] him let's see it's
something happened oh boy you seem
distracted we don't have to talk let's
see no I want to talk frantically typing
kind of I haven't told anyone about it
yet let's see I'm here for you you can
talk to me okay you just have to keep
the suck secret okay let's see you can
trust me em you have to promise not to
tell anyone
let's see cross my heart and hope to die
okay here we go here we go again gosh
let's see truth is I wanted to break up
with Jeff for a while with something
really stupid happening
okay a surprise seems part of it what
stupid what happened I tried last night
but he just refused well what do you
mean Jackie was throwing a party so I
was there hanging out was he I'll start
from the beginning okay and of course he
showed up because there's early back
well let's see oh did you talk to him I
think I remembered he was working in
November si si ah something specific
happened
yeah it was being different but like if
you want to talk to each other now
really is more of a bunch of little
things I see ah let's see you didn't
well I didn't why didn't you tell him
that last time to kill more a second he
got here uh is he came on to me there
was never a good time
see oh there's no such thing a good time
for that let's see ah how it's going on
how he got a new girlfriend he's got a
new girlfriend
I know it felt like there was too much
going on but I don't know I thought my
feelings might change let's see so he's
just stuck it out with him I see but
like he just started talking about li ER
Oh what about your breakup ho boy yeah
and some stuff was known but I was still
happy
that's C oh I'm so sorry and Mosby's
always making better make sure you hold
on to [ __ ] let's see did it make you
happy let's see yes sir I hang him out
that's the roar did he say back kind of
it's hard to sell he was sincere homeboy
no hard initially it was busy later but
eventually he said yet I've forgotten
overseas yeah we agreed to meet it's his
house let's see uh
oh I mean in his house it was nice to
talk about everything kids did you get
the closure let's see so I felt better I
don't know kind of people kept
interrupting and when I got there he
just started crying
see did you stand your ground and still
talk we ended up ditching going outside
let's see why did you ditch the party
yeah we still talked about everything
who oh just some where we could be and
then I made up my mind I want to break
up with him let's see what did ya stay
back oh boy it was really nice of him
yeah closure can be great po boy he was
quiet for a bit Oh cuz he then he
sounded no he just said no let's see
what's a father Evo boy yeah shouted it
he was like an angry huh I know the
[ __ ] did right stretch out
throw away how did you react okay grab
me let's see jeez upon him is he I don't
know what to do please tell me you punch
him you bet I did
Oh what an idiot let's see was Jimmy on
the bag huh boy sir shanab acting all
toying with him cause he's any [ __ ]
off did you go back to me yeah turned
into real kiss
eventually just left it went home now I
ended up just walking home [ __ ] that's
not even the worst of it oh no what
happened yeah I didn't notice too so I
got this morning see what a job dang
that's hee haw his Jeff for him huh
Steve went back to the partying told
everyone about us see I said I tried to
kiss him yeah I like it or not
biggie you serious homeboy see I know
Jackie does everything for everyone
so yeah Japan oh no no not that one oh
my god what dominions oh what a bunch of
minions that's not what I meant
what about core sampler couldn't say
anything this is just what sir let me
why are you responding okay just
thinking about what is they all my
friends not your friend then who sounds
like they're not your friends then well
I'm gonna go goddamnit
let's see I'm here now am I did you feel
like such an idiot I should have seen
him coming see you know who he is now
don't call me that you know I guess I
was wrong about us it's like you oh man
see you are wrong about us
oh boy okay that is set up for failure
that is straight-up set up for failure
it is like that particular one there's
human reaction times they're not fast
enough for that [ __ ] laws my friends
okay
real friends will day I'm sorry for
being so weak let's see honestly I'm
really glad you came to me and we can
talk about it
whoo-hoo thanks a lot for letting me
vent what do you think about the whole
situation
let's see Steve is an [ __ ] playing
simple
Jabar huh
what should I do about him let's see
well tell girlfriend yeah tell
girlfriend that's probably a good idea
tried to kiss you my hand is cramping so
bad let's see she deserves to know the
kind of scumbag he's dating oh man my
hand is cramping so bad
[ __ ] oh my god ha won't you I do about
my friends
let's see tell them the truth about what
happened I mean if they're real friends
they'll either go with it you know
they'll they'll believe you or you know
let's see your true friends will that's
the one I was trying to say ah okay I'll
tell them the truth - helping me with
all this mark oh my god [ __ ] ah
and I'm Evy I'm always there for you
[ __ ]
it really hurts like I'm not even joking
this vlogging hurts I cramped up my my
pinky really bad you get pretty good
advice Fe oh I'm really glad you were
able to talk to who you don't have to
lie I was an emotional wreck let's see
let's see
aw come on no you weren't oh here's ago
tonight was really nice of you you I
know you'd do the same for me Wow just
like don't go anywhere okay see where
would I go ah you're such a genuine
person that I am that I am not so glad
that the needy
- second response time Emily over there
you're not as judgmental of dad [ __ ]
it's not often you find someone like
that you know let's see let's see
ah that's you - you know that's your
good lets you two
I guess there's no secret that you mean
a lot to me like I don't really know
what to call us see ya
I feel we're not just friends yeah I
would think of that too
I'm glad you feel the same way
oh I'm glad too I don't want to like
label us or whatever but I don't know I
really like you
let's see I like you too
like you do I don't know if I call you
my favorite just yet I just hope we're
always this close or even closer sorry
that's not necessary
maybe we can hang out tomorrow it'd be
so nice to not think about this drama
sounds great
can you bring a nice back for my wrist I
think I can can easily got carpal tunnel
from that I don't know maybe hang on
just listen to music or something you
could bring your favorite alternative
CDs over let's see yeah that'd be kind
of fun a bit kind of fun awesome saucy
hell yeah oh man are you tired
let's see not all of you yeah I think I
might call it a night I'll definitely
see you tomorrow
see whether you like it or not I will be
there always
let's see you will you will that's all
that sounds like a threat good night ego
one night Evie right oh [ __ ] yeah so I
don't know how you could possibly
possibly keep up with Evie's with
Emily's conversation there because Emily
was flying way faster than Evie was or
maybe that was just me from what I saw
but it seemed like it
like it just seemed like Emily's
conversation was going way faster and
way way meteor-like I'm not saying like
oh she was meaty but she was a little
needy and it was like [ __ ] it didn't
respond in two seconds come on I'm only
human here even if I was just talking to
you that'd be hard
huh but we're moving on moving on how
could anybody do that
or maybe it's setup that you either
jumble the conversation with Evelyn or
Emily depending on which one you're
focused on more but frankly like I did I
did good on both I don't know if anyone
would ever be able to do both okay
ah t-pain Linkin Park let's see uh ah
pause of course yeah let's see yeah we
all have scars I've got scars I've got
lots of scars hey best friend yo u yo
you [ __ ] water
Boop I know we really chilled today but
I miss u m-z ah hang out tonight
[Music]
I wish have so much homework due
tomorrow oh look
what are you up to oh you know uh just
homework - I just asked you what you
would already know what you're doing
what's great people here
[ __ ] Kel bells let's see what's the
project oh we have to write a poem is
there a prompt for it yeah but it's
super vague what should I write about
you straight about me obviously so
[ __ ] interesting I'm like realist I
think I can do that I really like this
class hopefully an easy a - anyone know
doing it I don't think so I didn't know
anyone ever junior but some of the
people in it are pretty cool let's see
I'm jealous
that's how it's going Matt attack oh
yeah
guess what no chicken but no I've been
trying to get into alternative because
it's your favorite and I found a song
that's halfway there
Oh sending to me oh that's so nice
shared interest I'm ready let's see
we're good
oh nice nice that's good stuff that's
good stuff em let's see I liked it a lot
I actually like this one there's good
stuff that's good look [ __ ] yeah it's
well see oh man jack is blowing up my
phone right now let's see oh oh what's
going on oh nothing crazy she's trying
to plan a big party who is this party
same that is prom it's an anti-prom
party speak just pee oh oh yes let's see
what do you want to do want to skip it
together you click prom I didn't go to
prom everybody can go to prom at all you
want skip prom and hang out skip it
together like as in a date let's see
yeah that's cool you fighting go to prom
hoodies go to prom yeah so when you were
gonna ask me let's see ah glad I said
yes cuz I'm so desperate like I would
have said no is that the stupidest smile
right now oh I wanna see [ __ ] send me
your smile put in an envelope and send
to me I've wanted us to be a thing for
so long hey me too
eg baby me too can I like call myself
your girlfriend I say that is not
allowed
let's see no but I can call you my
girlfriend yeah Dale's a [ __ ] so
smooth okay here comes trouble you see
you better be [ __ ] cool we can
definitely have more way more fun just
us let's see
prom is definitely overrated
so what do we do for our date Oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate the beach yeah I've been to
the beach in so long oh why cause I
don't like to go confession I'm not the
best swimmer
let's see Oh neither am i in fact I
won't touch the ocean not on your
goddamn life
oh sure it'll be fine we won't die what
should we do after ah
Jackie's party yeah it would be a great
way to end the day
[ __ ] rebel God so cool [ __ ] damn
right we're super badass [ __ ] yeah we
are [ __ ] yeah
hey do you mind if I brings up something
semi-serious let's see I'm home I'm
always serious baby I'm always serious I
just really wanted to thank you for
helping me with this Steve drama this
winter I really needed you and you were
there for me oh well I just know you
would have done the same for me I would
have really your advice to contact
Steve's girlfriend and tell my friends
the truth was incredible oh did your
friends believe you when you told them
the truth good advice I got good advice
yeah they're good I mean Steve was a
predictable [ __ ] he kind of broke
away from our group after that but
enough about that I just wanted to say
meant a lot to me you mean a lawyer
Rooney uh-huh
it's just nice knowing you were real
yeah
that you're still around even though you
know the real me and I know the real you
Oh always will be married it up babies
oh yeah you know it's stupid I used to
think we were incompatible for reasons
like I drink and you don't cuz it'll
kill you but it's really actions that
matter not stupid stuff like that let's
see uh couldn't say it better myself god
I didn't know what I was gonna say I
didn't have words in my brain to
understand of that how different can
even be better
ah it's really happy that we're a thing
it's pretty swell I'm happy too I'm
really really happy too that we're
complete polar opposites yeah okay it
should get out of it is my writing
project that was fast
something tells me I don't believe you
but you know I'm gonna whatever you can
see alright let's open up this bad right
it's about you kinda bombs are weird
all right let's I'm just gonna read it
to you guys someone find someone who
makes you smile who listens when you
speak who likes you for you tell someone
that you like making them smile that you
listen to their every word that you like
them for them
no someone exists for you and know you
exist for someone oh god I'm so turned
on right now
[ __ ] that's a me a my to someone hey
baby
is that is that me am i I've act someone
Amano one maybe well I don't know you're
just this inspiration that's one of my
last bit of homework now I'm go to burn
and leave me what I know it's the
saddest thing I just we can't wait to
get super comfy and warm under some
covers ice what I want to be warm I want
to be comfy inform that's like my
favorite food I wish we could cuddle
let's see
make out huh if you're lucky
whoo yeah yeah hopefully we can get in
some alone time when we skip prom oh I
think that's that's guarantee all that
rare looking guarantee ah
come see ya so [ __ ] smooth good idea
one good just I'm so goddamn smooth
I am so goddamn smooth ah look bud hello
hi hi hi hi what's up what's up I know
we haven't talked in like a while let's
see I know it's okay whatever we like
talked for a little bit I could get
whatever seekers I was here for you you
ran away I just want to say some stuff
about January okay okay
I'm here for you
I'm really sorry for getting mad at you
no I'm sorry the whole thing was my
fault I take full responsibility for my
[ __ ] up actions I know you didn't like
owe me anything I just thought you'd be
there for me I don't know let's see I
should have been I should have been
there for I should have faster reflexes
should I add the tippy tappy true
believe it diabetes should I had these
magic butterfingers okay mmm you were
taking so long girl uh Cup three seconds
what were you doing while we were
talking let's see I was talking to
someone else that's just the honest
truth it's the truth I was talking to
someone else talking to who was it
really important Evelyn oh I promise not
to tell let's see was it really
important ah
I promise not to tell I promised I
promised not to tell anyone B yeah it
was important okay
I was just worried you like didn't want
to deal with me or something Oh God
definitely not the case that's
definitely not the case I was I was
there for you I was just feeling really
lost and you weren't there I was there
my fingers fell off they eroded away did
his nerves I guess maybe I unloaded too
much baggage like all at once
let's see I don't think no way we were
just talking I didn't feel like
overwhelmed thank you for saying that I
just feel so embarrassed for it like
whenever we talked you were always so
composed and here I was just being a
complete mess I can be [ __ ] too everyone
can be a I'm just a bag good thank you
so much for talking to me mark hey thank
you for messaging me reversed
I'm so [ __ ] smooth so I guess we're
officially talking again let's see it's
official
yay blows it on face milk I'm glad it's
been a while see how happy and I'm here
for you interesting I've been grand all
I've been swell me and Jeff finally
broke up like a month ago yeah it's been
really nice being single see he didn't
refuse again I remember shouting nose oh
no he did but this time I was ready and
now college is coming up soon be ready
to lube really Moscow fresh start
New York so ready I've met some new
friends though one of them I think you
know pretty well let's see oh really
dude that your debt el balloon huh just
your best friend Emily she's really
grand let's see
quite a quotes around best friend she
talks about you sometimes it's clear
you're not just friends let's see
oh nice to hear nice here how do you
know her she's in my running class she
sat next to me one day Jeff's in that
class too so it was really nice of her
Oh sounds like her yeah that does sound
like her that does that sounds like her
a lot
she's like really pretty too let's see
so so are you yeah that's a douchey
thing to say I know right
she's gorgeous [ __ ] god damn it well I'm
glad you're doing well I know Emily's
not like I'm not gonna like and I'm
really glad we're messaging again let's
see it yeah it's been way too long let's
keep talking all night it really has
sorry if this is getting sappy again
could be sappy er I think it could be
Sam here with two R's challenge accepted
oh boy incoming honestly I really miss
talking to you let's see
I missed it - Mistah - with two three
O's I think what I miss most was just
talking about nothing if that makes
sense you like to room you do you yeah I
give three you just ramble on for years
what our faves like yeah you so spot see
oh now you're just lying me yeah I got
Bert solid DS haha yeah I've missed this
C uh well this ain't going nowhere M if
I can be so bold as to call you that if
you would call me eagle - that'd be
compared sorry but do you think you can
call me Emily oh oh oh what oh I guess
oh no Emily whatever thank you whatever
whatever I don't want to steal your
whole night I think I'm gonna go and see
on a monitor we can still talk whatever
weirder
okay I'm so bored I'm just whatever
thanks for talking to me though it means
a lot
whatever thank you - we're talking -
let's just thank each other endlessly
whatever whatever bye bye don't [ __ ]
need it huh
you're gonna be off like that I don't
need it
you know what fun good fun forever it's
just so nice knowing you're real and
that you're still around even though you
know the real media oh I must have
screen shorted it well this is the last
chapter the last ever it seems like it
seems like you could go multiple ways in
this you could it's like a choice right
it's like a choice you stay true to one
or two to the other it's not like you
can do both because they're in the same
class together eventually so flick that
would not be an option
ooh modders mouse let's see uh
ratatouille is my favorite movie I
[ __ ] love ratatouille mistakes aren't
always regret that's good stuff that's
good stuff right there hey hi what are
you what I am away what what a dick
what are you want so listen you know how
me and your girlfriend are like friends
see yeah I do I do I know that well we
were talking today and she brought you
up and I don't know some of the stuff
she was saying just didn't make sense to
me let's see what do you mean what do
you mean hmm whoa whoa what's that
they're like who you are seem different
from the you I knew okay okay so I don't
know I told her that
is he all right yeah why would you do
that
mmm I don't know it seemed wrong not to
say something officer okay all right
then fine I just thought she should know
the truth or my version of it let's see
what do you even mean by that like who
you really are you don't know me I don't
know you should doctor I'm sorry if I
messed things up see but you don't know
me at all
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Emily seriously [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
let's see hey does he
hey Amy uh-huh yeah okay what are you up
to
Oh talking to people you nothing let's
see how are you I'm feeling down hmm
my brains doing the thing where it won't
[ __ ] off again let's see let's see I'm
here for you if you want it Locke I'm
here I do yeah but it's hard
oh no rush you take your time I got all
night
God you don't know what I want to say
[ __ ] you and I don't think you can help
with this let's see I can try to I can
try it's just oh I guess we just need to
talk let's see oh yeah yeah I heard
Emily told me oh yeah she told me
something interesting today oh yeah
what'd she tell you here we go emotional
burdens of high schoolers
so I brought you up basically saying our
cool our relationship is she told me
that the two of you used to be close
let's see - we used to be yeah we used
to be not really anymore I kind of told
her to [ __ ] off
well she told me a lot about you it
seems like the version of you she knew
is different than the one I know let's
see how did she tell you I was different
oh she said [ __ ] I guess you told
her you didn't want a [ __ ] family
like what the [ __ ] mark you told me you
wanted to settle down let's see hmm she
does like this thing right because I
wasn't lying when I made that answer
because it's bold like eventually I
think I do want a family but not right
away so it's like it's hard to say which
is the truth let's see let's see all
right fine you're right
I'm sorry I did that yeah I did that
[ __ ] sorry that's all you have to say
oh come on
what a bunch of baloney one of the
reasons I liked you in the first place
was you wind the same life as me um I
thought you understand me let's see see
see but I do understand you I do oh oh
no you don't you lied just to get close
to me okay
yeah you don't know the full story
you never asked me you got a surface
answer then you didn't ever get anything
explained I think the problem is I do
know the full story
[ __ ] I expected this from someone like
Steve but not like you hey that's not
fair that's a low blow
don't you think that's a [ __ ] low
blow go just compare me to your ex don't
do that you really not see the
comparison I don't even know who you are
anymore
let's see cause you do you can set these
super details don't matter oh that's not
what I said I wouldn't have said that
second action it's the actions that
Yeah right and you [ __ ] lied and
manipulated me let's see that's not what
happened you're creating a narrative the
walking the truth okay then what did did
you lie to me about settling down
I lied to Emily okay I lied but to Emily
not to you so you just told Emily what
you wanted to hear that's not any better
you see how sketchy it like see it's not
sketchy at all I was telling you the
truth
ah [ __ ] this isn't like this isn't what
I would have said because it's not a lie
you can't just know what you want when
you're in high school
let's see you're still trying to
manipulate Emily let's see let's see I'm
not some kind of mastermind it wasn't
like that if people are acting like they
don't ever ever tell like white lies to
try to agree with your friends it's a
bunch of [ __ ] what were you doing
let's see what it seemed like that's
what she wanted me to say so you try to
connect with her by being a fake version
of yourself
that's [ __ ] up mark you understand
that let's see you're just not seeing it
from my perspective it was nothing hmm
see oh who knows how many times you've
impressed me by being manipulative
Lizzie I have never and would never
manipulate you what have you lied to me
about not being a virgin bash what well
I didn't lie that I didn't and death the
end of that how can I know that I can't
trust what you say well then there's no
point in being in a relationship if you
can't trust what I say what of our
entire relationship is based on a bunch
of lies I promise you it's not let's see
oh sorry this is all real if you don't
want it then you can leave
you're a liar nothing's real with you
let's see I've answered everything come
on I've answered everything you've asked
me truthfully what I had to figure out
this lie you hid it from me if there
were more lies you would just hide them
from me to see I'm nodding anything
that's the truth believe me or not
you've already proven yourself missus
[ __ ] [ __ ] how do you expect me to
believe anything you say now see you
know how much I care about you you know
that's real is it though oh [ __ ] you
then the person I was dating was a
figment of my imagination let's see I
think I'm still the same person you're
dating av still same person I'm your
little one I want that to be true I
really do
we'll see let me keep in - you know I
really don't want to lose you I want
this to work that's the truth that's
just it
what would I what would I benefit let's
see what should I do
what'll I do then what'll I do what do i
do what do I do
I don't know I just need to be able to
trust you again
trust bills with time maybe all we need
to do is wait oh that's not what I
wanted yeah it can you see you're my
favorite thing well I really do care
about you you know that right why would
that be fake I know and I care about you
- and see see we've always been close
remember prom this year you mean do I
remember skipping prom see we're
definitely better than going pretty
badass if you ask me such rebels ha yeah
we are skipping was definitely the right
decision let's see yeah it really was
the way to go all be mine a manipulative
nature may not happen we do have some
pretty great memories together let's see
we really do ruin when we first met I
don't but tell me how that happened mr.
B says oh yeah history class yeah see he
sat us next to each other randomly you
see uh he must have really regretted
that little hit I think I was going
through some drama or something but I
remember you made me feel better you see
we both ditched Oh what did we do
I don't remember what we did I think we
passed notes yeah we started talking
about passing notes back and forth yeah
that's what it was okay there we go
yeah oh man is he I think he knew about
them cool like that yeah that's what mr.
B was he's so career I wonder what he
would think about us now I remember I
roll my screen name down secretly inside
your binder I love it I took a page I'm
gonna hung up on the wall but it must
ride Evelyn and the rest is history
you see ah I think I knew from that
first day that I liked to I think I did
yeah yeah yeah yeah now I'm starting to
cry
let's see what's wrong why are you
crying I don't know we were so perfect
but now those memories just kind of hurt
I don't understand why do those memories
hurt I just can't stop doubting like
every aspect of our relationship see
please believe me our feelings are real
I'm trying I'm really trying let's see
uh right now not a time for a
declaration of I love you but it's
either I got to go for a Hail Mary or I
can play the safe route nah I love you
Evelyn yeah that's it go for the Hail
Mary Hail Mary I just is gonna work yeah
I can't believe you see what can I do
you can't believe me what can I do then
if my Hail Mary isn't enough then
goodbye I thought bringing this up in
arguing would help like at the end we'd
make up and be okay let's see we're
still not okay if that's the way it is
tell me right no we're not
says you I just feel used and gross and
stupid let's see you're not any of those
things
mom I feel like I'm in a soap opera now
oh that's just how I feel I can't change
that let's see I understand
okay you're right I understand oh this
is always [ __ ] [ __ ]
King thanks I don't know what to do
let's see you want some time alone we
could talk again in a bit
no I don't think more time will help
blue blue maybe we should spend some
time apart for a while that like what
you want I don't know what I want green
this is hurts a lot
let's see yeah this really hurts for me
too I love my wounded soul
huh II I mean college is coming up
anyway see maybe this is it
see I don't want I really don't want a
drink up but I won't force your hand
need to do i but just talking to you is
making me upset you'll see I'm sure if
you just give this some time I don't
want time to have to fix this
you see okay well then I get a breaking
up yeah I guess so I don't want to stop
talking to you I don't want to stop
either see
[Music]
I hope so
but right now I just don't know I
thought we were such a good couple yeah
I thought so too
Suzy very loose on sad desperation I'm
not the one who did this out logoff
goodbye
all right you can now sign out okay all
right then good god that's so sad it's
bad for multiple [ __ ] al it's sad for
multiple reasons ooh it's sad for
multiple reasons to like it it really is
it's really sad because like it's it's
so crazy that like it's just so crazy
that and that was such a small thing and
there was no convincing there was no
convincing that of what that was you
know what I mean there's no convincing
you and 50.3% talk to Evelyn you and
89.9% were more than friends you and 42%
got this ending your friend cinnamon
toast ken did too so anyway that is
Emily is a way to it I feel like a piece
of [ __ ] you know and I and it's an
instrument of my own destruction it's
like God I don't know why why it makes
me feel like this because in the end of
the game so like I was playing to win
and I ah it unravels with one tiny thing
aha
suck so much oh why does it make me feel
why am I an idiot
oh [ __ ] but then again it's like
high-school drama it's not my fault
those are minor mana comes of detail
there huh but anyway that is Emily as a
way to that is the end and that's all
there is for now thank you everybody so
much for watching I know there's
probably numerous numerous endings to
this game and there's probably numerous
ways to play I don't even know if
there's a way that you could like try to
court both of them and it's just I don't
know it's nuts I I just like I just find
it fascinating that it ended up that way
because the problem is is on chapter 3
like chapter 3 uh during that dynamic
duo of events like I don't think there's
any way to go through that like you'd
have to memorize it beforehand but then
even so you have to type you have to tip
tap with your fingers and that was
really slowing me it's not just picking
the choices you have to type it in huh
and it was set up for failure so either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching
play this game for yourself it's really
cool there's probably tons and tons of
different endings that you can get to
and it's my fault it's my quali for
trying to go for both that is my quality
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]